merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
un brin de cohérence c'est de bon sens
n'a jamais nuit surtout à un
gouvernement alors où la défiance
populaire envers la parole publique et
atteint des sommets mieux vaut une
République exemplaire permettez-moi donc
de m'interroger sur une contradiction de
votre gouvernance une règle certes
informelle mais inlassablement répété
depuis 25 ans veut qu'un ministre
abandonne c'est mandat exécutif locaux
avec une mission à un objectif simple se
consacrer entièrement à sa mission
gouvernementale l'immense majorité de
votre gouvernement s'est plié à cette
règle rejoignant ainsi les
parlementaires pour qui le nom cumule et
non pas une règle mais une loi que le
précédent gouvernement auquel vous
apparteniez à refuser d'assouplir l'an
dernier cependant il reste quelques
récalcitrant
mère président d'assemblée ultra-marine
président d'agglomération et même
président d'un département dans le cas
du ministre des Armées y aura-t-il donc
des ministres privilégiés de fortes
têtes capricieux un problème d'autorité
de votre part Madame le Ministre
comptez-vous enfin faire appliquer cette
règle que le mini le chef de l'État
lui-même avait rappelé en 2017 allez
vous faire démissionner de leur mandats
locaux les ministres concernés
[Applaudissements]